is
[Music]
[Music]
you'll be down to bring the family alone
by the spot on the lawn and play this
song
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we embrace
man right on your face
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like a 6am
[Music]
we'll walk into the sunrise
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
baby welcome to the world famous
stuttering john podcast with your
favorite world famous host stuttering
john melendez coming at you straight
from the beautiful canoga park
little mexico as i like to call it
but there's a taco stand on every corner
oh i love it here though great people
here at the
the
melendez estate in canoga park
and i hope you're all having a good day
uh mine started off pretty crappy um
well the yankees rained out again today
come on now
have i i haven't had my yankees now for
two straight days
three eat it
they were off thursday rained out friday
and it rained out saturday
maybe we should put a dome over that
stadium eh
anyway there's the link if you want to
donate paypal.me
slash john melendez inc
joni heisenberg as usual the first in
the room hi john the judge in georgia
has denied the petition to remove
marjory trailer green from the ballot
yep i know that one
we'll talk about that with tony michaels
gabe sanchez and the great greg oliart
uh
joni with zero proof ted cruz
irresponsibly stated he believes it is a
clerk with justice sotomayor that leaked
the scottish people yeah it wouldn't
wouldn't that be what
ted cancun cruise would say
i think though
uh
sony republican candidate andrew wilhate
charged with murdering miss kant's
stricken wife with a
blunt object wins indiana primary from
jail
you can't write this folks
you really cannot write this
i mean
i mean this is just amazing to me
joanie
justice clarence thomas we can't be an
institution that can be bullied into
giving you just the outcomes you want
his wife jenny attempted to do just that
by seeking help to overturn the election
i agree joanie
m bezler i found embezzler i finally got
it
i found john because i'm a huge fan of
don wenzel but i love john's show so
much i am happy i joined so much has
happened this past weekend can't wait to
hear everyone's thoughts well thank you
embezzler
sophia
melikara what's up joni justice lido
cited misogynistic
uh sir matthew hale nine times in his
98-page league draft opinion hal
supported marital rape and had women
executed for witchcraft
unbelievable shorty one is here joanie
bipartisan is not some
something we should even want anymore
because to work with these people is to
see ground to fastest
mary trump said that and joanie agrees
and i do too
admiral sulu would you consider going
back to dc with your own first rape
production crew
can't believe godzilla let you down you
deserve much better yeah guns i've never
showed
i don't know why germany san francisco
judges have dismissed trump's lawsuit
against twitter for banning him from the
platform elon musk denied devin newton's
claim that trump had encouraged him to
buy
twitter
musk twitter buyout
challenged and shareholder lawsuit tony
julie svenson with the badge good as
gold good as gold i have i have to take
exception with goods gold today mark p
with the badge
um
but his goal gregory had a great guest
on his podcast i forget him anybody use
some comments
this is
useless uh joanie uh there we go roberta
knight is here with the badge jm vandy
with the badge
uh
gerard sullivan
roberta knight with the badge mark p
with the badge mark curly from my
ireland
goodies gold by the way i bought the
book strong and by ruth benkeit and also
bought before evil by golthia who greg
had on his podcast can't wait to read
them
both uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
baby
johnny heisberg julian is refusing to
testify testify before john's chance x
committee unless he can film it
if anybody
should not ask to be filmed it's rudy
giuliani with his [ __ ] die streaming
down the right side of his face
his hair died
cb stage dog
facebook people joining this broadcast
you can support my page by sending stars
a digital gift that helps me earn money
the tony michaels podcast is here sherry
p
um
joe weatherford with the bench marco
v193
i was very sorry
to see you left my patreon marco v
uh
julie's fencing with the bay jamie
steele
uh
medium tea christina garcia she loves
the intro thanks to the usa singers
stacy hogan mr calamaggi mexicali maggie
it is derby day
yvonne watkin
my mom is here frankie smith chess
flexer
andrea mccready
kenneth otto with the badge
uh carlene martin from iowa quaver
um
tim farrell
uh
trying to go fast here to bring my
guests on linda mcewen
patty freeburn
anita blake
uh
jill carter with the badge
uh
forrest ritchie from high castle
uh batboy999 who did the theme music the
usa singers
although every time i try and get those
bastards on like they're always too busy
but i guess they are you know
you know they have a
recording studio or something but
take some time and promote your brand
dummies martha salinas
amy denis linville
john davenport
uh
let's see
big j21
oh it's super chat saturday that's right
thank you for reminding me big
yeah
it is super chat saturday keep them
coming
still absorbing all the cash i was had
to spend
jaclyn 2020 and
all for a [ __ ] crew
that judge seemed to be crushing on
margery spark foot so no surprise there
that's true
lacey carter
central strewnut serves screwing to one
diane lamp
uh
hey todd jackie hobson
uh all right all right
tim farrell
how about the guy giving the judge bell
to the kid john that's how we canadians
roll i'm not sure i saw that story benny
loco first super chat of the day
was in the loo hello everyone
tmi benny
thanks for the two bucks
uh let's see
crystal fits you
keep those facebook stars coming
janelle walker chris derrickson
uh the thing i was going to say about
goods go she said i look like the
long-haired guy here and come on that
guy's fat with a
i don't know he looks like ron jeremy
come on
uh i don't jamie still i don't i believe
a word aim amber heard says too
uh
uh
okay
uh
[Music]
uh let's see
uh you know john def i i don't know i
don't commenting on the stand-ups i i
that's something i i don't do
you know
unlike these other people who really
don't you know
understand
it's not cool
la masando shot
marco v 193 i begged a different left
patreon to join youtube ah
sorry marco v thanks for the five bucks
did not i did not know that
jen sieg
uh
chez edo
andrea brower
uh chris derrickson
uh
yeah
oh fellow the
clown uh
thanks for the 10 bucks stupid question
did you really wash your hand for every
one of howard's potatoes
i did i did wash my hands because i knew
he was a germaphobe but
you know i did
i did clean the potatoes in the sink in
the bathroom because we didn't have a
kitchen
so that's the only place i can do it
until howard walked in it was like
[Laughter]
uh
yeah
the good old days carol helbert from
uh quebec
and now
we can move along with the show
so uh
a lot going on
in the world of the gqp
and
we'll discuss that at length
right now
on super chat saturday don't forget it
wasn't rigged you're just a loser thanks
to the midas touch brothers who are
coming on soon
man
have i been working we got some great
guests
coming on soon starting this tuesday
with someone i won't even mention
but you will be very happy
to talk to this person then the
following tuesday uh another congressman
thank you
thank you
who's better than me
well i'll tell you who tony michaels
how are you john sanchez are that's
who's better than me how you doing guys
good how are you i i thought i was going
to be your guest on tuesday you're like
oh you're going to have this fantastic
guess i'm like i'm on today john what
the hell what the hell well you know
tony i really appreciate it because
look
so you know my saturday guests are
usually house sparks unfortunately he
lost
like one of his closest friends oh no
that's horrible yeah his friend kurt so
i asked him if he wanted to come on he's
like now so i understand you know i get
it i get it well we were on on last week
when you um yeah that was my favorite
that's one of my favorite recent shows
i mean that
i mean
i couldn't have planned it better to
have the both of you guys on to laugh at
the crew
shooting my video sideways right right
well i i was i was praying i even text
gabe i said i hope he doesn't make us
watch the
dc footage again so
it was new dc footage right right no no
no no
but you know i was talking to my
moderator and she was like
john you couldn't have planned that
better because tony and gabe on that
show was the perfect casting
because you know just to hear you
goofing it and me goofing and it was
just like
it was like a cut it was a it was a
comedy show wrapped around a political
show yeah right yeah it was uh let's
just let's just say the the footage
that did or did not happen in dc um one
way or the other is absolutely hilarious
and not that
um that the footage itself is hilarious
necessarily just the circumstance and
the result
around the uh craigslist um
crew that you found
[Laughter]
i tried you know look guys i just want
you know in my defense
i tried doug goodstein a producer i
tried another producer friend of mine i
tried my nephew he didn't have a he
didn't have a camera that hooks too much
but i was
uh you know exhausting all avenues
before i put that craigslist ad up there
but even then you would think somebody
who says that he's an experienced
videographer would know
not to turn the phone sideways
right link yeah or you know to bring an
extra battery right yeah or a battery
that is charged at all really yeah yeah
i mean that would help
it'll help in his defense he said he got
it from the camera house and they gave
it to him on charge
and uh the what house the nut house is
that what you said didn't happen again
you also brought a camera stand
for
one-on-one interviews which i i i did
yeah like like a tripod or like a like a
stick stand a tripod stick stand you
know you put the camera on right right
well i mean there's this there's a stick
stand that you sit on the ground you
know and right like that's like you're
taking like a monopod kind of right yeah
monopod you can hold it
right right
like if you if you have a tripod in
certain areas
uh they'll require you to have a permit
i remember that happening in san
francisco no [ __ ] yeah anytime i wanted
to photograph or take video in public in
certain areas as soon as the tripod went
down on the ground they're like do you
have a permit or do you have permission
to be here oh [ __ ] but if i take the
tripod away and i just film on my camera
they're like oh yeah that's fine what
about a monopod what about the stick pod
were they they i don't know i mean i
don't have one i've only tried with a
tripod well yeah well
i mean some people have one some people
don't get it look harry schmidt you
should have gotten a professional crew
but you're cheap that i cheaped out what
do you mean i cheaped out
i mean i mean i i tried to get doug
goodstein's crew for 500 a day i cheaped
out shut up
jesus
anyway um
i didn't i didn't mean to get us off on
a whole easy footage tonight we're gonna
watch this we're gonna watch the footage
one more time
no no i'm not you didn't want to i did
want to tell you guys
that um
that podcast i uploaded today and it's
now on itunes and everywhere else yeah
nice so uh so this is like a triple
header i had you on thursday or what
whenever it was no it was like it was
that was last saturday saturday yeah i
had you on last saturday
and you know and now
and now i have you on again today and
now i released the podcast yeah
and now i'm up to date with all my
pockets i don't know about you guys uh
do you upload your shows to itunes every
single day every day because because we
do a show every day so our our show goes
live on youtube twitter and twitch and
we do it live two hours monday through
friday do it all right live do it live
do it live god damn it do it live
um but but then so we broadcast too we
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page but what i what we do is we edit it
like we pull the audio as soon as we're
done and we edit the audio and then we
put the audio
on like the you know apple spotify so
usually like by three four o'clock in
the afternoon eastern time is usually
when the uh when it's up on the
directories to download so like every
single day we're doing two hours so wow
sometimes it's a lot i don't know about
you it's such a pain in the ass to
upload it because you got to use google
chrome because if you use safari it'll
take two days and then
you know then you got to upload it to
libsyn i don't know what you guys use
and then you got to
put the descriptions in then you got to
copy the link and it's like a whole it
takes like 20 minutes to get one show
off
john i bet if you put a craigslist down
there you could probably find something
you're gonna make you could you could
probably find somebody just one drive
aren't you oh man every single time
you're you're you're my guy who writes
my greatness
i'm telling you you're gonna you know
you gotta get a message
and i used to do unbeknownst to howard
when any time arty or and i tried to
squeeze in a joke if arty saw me do it
he'd go like this
as if
he's trying to crowbar in a joke
and whenever he did it like i remember
once he meant uh
he he mentioned uh i can't uh
a phillies player uh barry larkin and i
looked at him
and we used to always always always do
that so it was so funny speaking of
of the stern show yeah were you guys
fans of the stern show
you know i i mean i i i've liked um
howard's um provocative way for a long
time because i'm kind of a provocateur
right you know i like to stir the bot
but did you see the clip this this week
that he uh talked about the
uh supreme court we played it on our
show and um we actually went through it
you know a lot of people are fans of
howard some aren't um i know you have
good history bad history you know all
that kind of good stuff but uh the thing
that he said this week about about the
decision to reverse roe v wade um
i think rings true
and um
you know sometimes
love him hate him
stearns right you know i mean it's just
the way it is sometimes well no i know
it's you know it's odd that because when
i was with him
i mean everybody thought he was a
republican you know i mean because
that's what it always why would they
think that though because really like
like joe rogan or even stern
they're not political commentators right
so like why would they even have some
sort of ideology like i'm a political
commentator i don't even consider myself
a comedian or a comic i mean i try to
use comedy to get your attention but i
mean like when you're a commentator
right like it's
you have ideology ideology that's like
the whole point like you're you're
putting your stake in the sand as it
were but like howard doesn't i mean he
does political commentary just because
he's doing interviews right and he's
talking about the stuff that's happened
during the day but i mean he's talking
about [ __ ] johnny depp and amber
heard too which has nothing to do with
[ __ ] politics i know but i know that
people hate that he's gone all liberal
but
listen i don't agree with howard on
everything but the things is it really
liberal though john is it really liberal
to want people to have [ __ ] rights
this is ridiculous that it's
and i agree with everything he's saying
right like it's almost like if i saw
howard now i go thanks for you know
thanks for fighting the good fight
although he won't see me anymore
especially after my book but still
well you know sometimes you say things
about people and you know it happens but
but the thing is is that just because
howard
uh um
has an opinion and he has a microphone
like you can't you can't silence him and
you can't silence joe rogan right like
these these two are one in the same in
that like they don't really joe rogan's
a dumb blockhead hey hey listen listen
turns way brighter no
way more talented what i'm saying what
i'm saying is the audiences right
because you have audiences out there
that want to silence rogan you have
audience out there that want to silence
yeah but tony you know they wanted to
silence joe rogan because he's telling
people to take [ __ ] horsty warmer
instead of a [ __ ] vaccine he's
killing people well yeah well right but
but but that's that's that's really keep
stuttering tony that's really an
indictment that's really an indictment
of our education system in this country
i mean if people are [ __ ] dumb enough
to believe some of the [ __ ] that that
[ __ ] box joe rogan says well then if you
know what what are you gonna do what the
hell you gonna do i mean there's a hell
of a lot worse people out there that got
microphones not as big as joe rogan's
but just her [ __ ] dumb and just as
stupid and says dumber i i just think
that you have to have to accept some
some responsibility if you have five
million people who are listening to you
right and you are an anti-vaxxer i think
that you have to
you know
accept some responsibility for
for spewing
maltreats but don't you think that's
what howard's doing by by being
quote-unquote liberal like he's he's
standing up for people with his
microphone right like yes but he's not
he's not spreading disinformation no i'm
not saying that i'm not saying that but
but at the same at the same time we we
as a country have to [ __ ] get smarter
it's it's ridiculous that we've dumbed
everything down and i really don't think
we're dumber now than we were you know
20 years ago it's just with twitter and
social media it is way more prevalent
that we have some gum [ __ ] in this
country so i agree you know all right
now i'm the reason why i brought up
power is cause somebody posted this
picture on facebook
and
this is from his first book private
parts and and he calls this this this is
my
radio crew and i'll be talking to steve
grillo about it on my beer on the
balcony in an hour and a half but i do
want to get you take cause yes
yeah i'm going to tell you i'm going to
tell you my observations on this so far
and then and and then i'll let you speak
first of all there is uh
my radio crew so first of all this is
the best here okay
now
this is the funniest thing to me
howard stern's
stylist and i and i and i say that in
quotes
is ralph the berry boy ocerella
no but nirvana had just become
big
they were they had just become super
famous
and grunge
was the you know fashion of the day
right ralph doesn't have an original
bone in his body he dresses howard like
kurt copeland
i mean look at that dude look at the
boots on howard look
look
that was that was the scene man those
are some pretty sweet boots yeah but
howard's 50 years old
you got to be [ __ ] hit no matter how
old you are you know you're 93 you got
to put on some hit boots god damn it
come on
come on it's it's so lame
and then like in howard's second book
uh in miss america
uh
ralph's goofing on me because i'm in a
blue suit with brown shoes
john don't you know brown don't go with
blue i'm like oh my god every newscaster
in new york is dressed this is
brown does go with blue it's the ground
in the sky you dumb the end of it but
he's howard stylist i'll tell you this
i'll tell you this
when we were on a stern show
each show would laugh every outfit that
ralph put howard in and sometimes they'd
pull me aside and go look at this one
john and i'd look at it and
ralph had howard in a charlie brown
outfit i kid you not and i'm going oh my
god this is this is the emperor's
clothes here howard doesn't see that
he's looking like a dumbass
well i mean maybe that's the brilliance
of it though you know maybe i mean
i mean
it creates conversation you know yeah
you know we're talking and you're still
talking about it now we're still talking
about this picture in these [ __ ]
boots because okay everyone else is
dressed quite normally except for flow
high now now first let's get to scott
the engineer
scott the engineer is right here look at
the wig look at the fake wig
[Laughter]
come on guys hey i want to know who's
the guy down front that looks like a
professional um
uh
hiring camera crew guy yeah looks like
he knows that
there he is professional craigslist ad
writer right there a young
stuttering john
and by the way i want to say this to you
tony yeah go ahead i still fit and own
that t-shirt do you really what is it
does it have any holes or paint on it
nope that's my k-rock 92k
t-shirt
it's all framed and preserved so
how how did you like long hair did you
like long hair yes yes i unlike howard
had a rock and roll album out on
atlantic now
[Laughter]
we're not [ __ ] talking or anything are
we is it no no no i think so so you got
[ __ ] you know the bald one that look
but i love scott so you got
you know scott the bowler
then you got kurt cobain light then you
got the great
running stimpy voice
billy west and then you have the mullet
here's the mullet from from fred eric
nukes i mean norris there's the mullet
going which i think is hysterical
and then
robin's looking great i don't
now you can see why she's still smoking
hot yeah you can see why jim florentine
hit her you know right
i mean nice okay and now look at the
buoy
he's wearing a marvin the martian
t-shirt
now
the stash man yeah and look at the porn
star stash that's [ __ ] sweet
took the photo and was on set later that
day
and he couldn't get his lips over the
teeth he looks he looks
he looks like he looks like he hired the
craigslist crew to shoot his porn
i'm a big fan of the jcpenney hand over
the shoulder pose i know what's going on
here i know i love that pose it's like
look at that pose oh boy
but i think the coolest one in this
picture i don't want to say anything
but uh you know i think the coolest one
in this picture i don't want to down in
front
yeah i don't want to say i i'm i'm going
to tell you john i think i think robin
is a gorgeous woman she always has me
yeah
because because look at jackie i mean
he's wearing some free shirt some free
lobster shirt that he got out
that he got from a gig in maine and
that's he was probably on nutrition
because he's
or he's sucking in that big fat gut of
his because he always looked like he
swallowed a b what here is this what
year is this
1992 93 and then
john do you know how old i was in 1992
1992-1993 i don't know 10.
now not quite 10. not quite then yeah
but look calvin kitten there and goodbye
gabe were you born in 1990 1988 were you
even alive i was born i was
just what uh what well you know that was
a twinkle in someone's eye but look how
cool and good looking that guy he's got
the he's got the cross hanging from his
head the biceps the long hair were you
were you religious or was this just the
thing yeah i was religious in those days
oh you're [ __ ] full of [ __ ] wow he
was religious did you go to church did
you go to church yeah jesus over here
i was communioned and cun and confirmed
oh [ __ ] you're a catholic you raised
catholic yes i was of course of course
you were we're all three catholic did
you know that all three of us we raised
and then the guilt still gets me today
yeah oh like i like i was arguing with
my friends you know
i have this friend i love him to death
he's one of my oldest friends in the
world right
but he's arguing with me
that homosexuality is not allowed in the
bible and i go john it's just one
passage in leviticus which also says
that you can't eat shellfish i go just
like doug stanhope who's been on the
show you can't have your freaking bible
a la carte but you know it's like yeah
you can't pick it up
and here's the thing that i i always
have to drive home
the bible was written 500 years after
jesus's death
do you realize you haven't played a game
freaking telephone when you have 10
people and and then you tell one story
and by the time it gets back to you it's
been it's been distorted to
immense proportions imagine 500 years of
that
you just look at some of these bigots
that are out there and you just say did
you know jesus
was a was a brown dude who was a jew and
it really they [ __ ] used their [ __ ]
because you know jesus was actually a
socialist
that he wanted he wanted health care for
everyone do you wanted to meet people
he wanted to house them for free what's
this yep and
and he spoke aramaic and his name wasn't
jesus and and john the baptist's name
wasn't john and peter's not peter and
martin is not martin they all had
aramaic names you idiots
right well you know i mean you could
even say that jesus was like uh
just like a
a traveling magician in ways you know he
was doing he was doing tricks party
favors turning turning water into wine
making one fish turn into many fish
are you saying he was like uh
uh chris angel
yeah pretty much i would say exactly i
think he was doing the same helicopter
hook in the back tricks with the you
know over the canyon that's exactly what
jesus was doing and he was like bow down
before let me i tell you
hey uh thank you i becky carpenter 58
for the 20 bucks it's a hell of a
generous gift
uh happy mother's day to my mom thank
you yeah
and this is true
i gotta tell you my mom doesn't lie
this is how much that she wouldn't lie
if i didn't want to talk to somebody who
was calling i would say just tell them
you know i'm not here she goes
and then i would have to walk outside in
the snow in the winter in my underwear
just so she could say john isn't john
isn't in the house right now
this woman will not lie and here she
goes john went to church so he can get
candy because my father would bribe me
with candy and mad magazine after mass
oh my god
that's why i went i swear to you yeah i
never had that it was just the catholic
guilt that made me go
yeah well i'll tell you what
when i was an altar boy uh we would we
would be getting ready for uh for
service you know for mass and when and
in our and and the altar boy room where
we had all the robes and the wine we had
to prepare the wine there was like boxes
and boxes and boxes of wine like all
stacked against the wall so no one would
know if you drank a bottle or two of
that [ __ ] so by the time we were at mass
and doing service we were
us altar boys were [ __ ] wasted i mean
we were just drunk out for that you know
we're like 14 15 year old boys drinking
this nasty [ __ ] wine this communion wine
and getting drunk it was uh it was
fantastic it was good john it was good
were you ever going out there boy were
you an altar boy no no no what do you
mean
was i ever what was i ever what john
what are you going to say what are you
going to say you know twiddle with no no
no i i there was our our priest was not
a kid diddler he was he was he was not a
republican um
you know the i'm i mean you know hey you
gotta these days you got to watch out
for these
actually followed the word of christ was
a good person
yeah i i don't i mean he was a catholic
priest so i'm not sure you know
um how all that was shaking christopher
double oh seven mill thanks for the two
bucks people aren't ready but jesus was
a witch
[Laughter]
i don't know how much you explain these
uh these miracles okay all right great
smells well i'll look i'll explain the
walking on i'll explain uh the walking
down water it was low tide
yeah i mean he found his sandbar and was
like
chris angel did the same trick in las
vegas across the pool yep
no jesus baby jesus baby you know jesus
long hair i think he had long hair at
one point i don't know if he does
anymore oh yeah chris angel yeah chris
angel right didn't he yeah i did giggle
at spit in levittown long island oh
no digits so you met him huh
uh yes i actually like chris angel he's
actually a nice guy and we won't press
too hard on him here and he's got that
bad long island accent you know it
brings me straight to home
[Laughter]
[Music]
so getting into the news of the day sure
clarence thomas
in his ultimate
stupidity
said that people
should just deal with you know
you know you know if if if roe v wade is
overturned people just should deal with
outcomes that they don't like
okay clarence
really
we should deal with you taking
the reproductive rights of women
out of their hands and giving their
vaginas to [ __ ] creepy men like you
who i don't care what you say assaulted
anita hill yeah clarence and your
dumbass wife who helped incite an
insurrection you should be thrown off
the court
well the thing i don't the thing the
thing that i you know i look at what he
said he was like oh you know we're not
gonna be bullied into uh to making a
public opinion you know basically he's
he's you know like the republicans he's
like i'm the victim but let's remind
yourself clarence thomas sits on the
highest court in all of the land right
he's married to as you said an
insurrectionist it seemed like anything
we are high yeah
and he wants to control women's bodies
like can somebody tell me how he's being
bullied and how he's the victim somebody
make it make sense yes
good point gabe you want you want me to
make it you want me to make it well i
mean like i know the answer but sure
yeah please you want you want to make it
make sense all these this is a gabe and
tony show what's going on all these all
these all these [ __ ] all these [ __ ]
are bought and paid for
um by the conservative establishment i
showed a video
on the show the other day and i post on
my twitter
and it shows this pastor
and and he
he wasn't like caught saying this [ __ ]
in his church he set up a [ __ ] camera
now it's not a craigslist cruise like a
you know like a you know he had a
professional you know camera it was it
was on a tripod but yeah right it was on
a tripod but he
so he's filming himself saying this [ __ ]
but he literally is saying that women
should not have the right to vote we
should take away the right to vote to
women and not only that he does not want
women ruling over this country in any
shape or any fashion and he thinks that
that is giving women rights like this is
what they want to do they are coming
after
the vote like everyone thinks oh you
know it's all hyperbole when when red
states are gonna you know overturn roe v
wade and blue states will have it
[ __ ] they're not going to stop at
just the you know they're not going to
go oh yeah we won okay now we can quit
they're going to go to the blue states
they're going to make it illegal they're
going to make it a felony in the red
states to have an abortion or receive a
medical procedure that would save your
life in another state
missouri the state i live in is trying
to make it a felony there's a law right
now they're trying to pass to make it a
felony to go to illinois and receive a
medical procedure if you're a woman
a felony they're going to make you a
felon and in some states
felons can't vote
i'm telling you they're coming after not
just the right to choose what you can
and can't do with your body they are
going to come after the vote of people
who want to have liberty they're
hell-bent on it and they're coming after
it they're saying it out loud they're
saying it out loud and part of this
part of this
is because and uh clarence thomas says
institutions are are eroding the
confidence of them is eroding and uh you
know this is [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
because he's the one that has eroding
confidence like the supreme court
by what they did by by the federal
society buying and paying for these
supreme court justices to make the
decision to take away our constitutional
rights is the thing that is eroding it
you [ __ ] bonehead to clarence thomas
and you're [ __ ] queuing on crazy ass
wackadoo
nuttier and squirrel turds wife
genie thomas
that is the explanation is they really
don't give a [ __ ] about you they don't
give a [ __ ] about you they don't care
they don't give a [ __ ] they're going to
do what they want to do how they want to
do it because the way they see it
they've had enough of this people having
right stuff because it creates equality
it creates equity and they ain't gonna
have any of that kind of [ __ ] yep
crystal double oh seven mill thanks for
the two dollars betcha thomas was the
leaking to get the heat off could be i i
don't doubt it for i mean
tony and i talked about it this week on
the show which is like you know
sooner or later these people who are
like pro fascists they're waving those
flags around at disney world and trying
to you know restrict people's rights and
suppress people votes as actual fascists
and actual tyrants like these people are
soon gonna look around once all these
things have been taken away whether it's
a woman's right to choose how she wants
to handle her body the right to uh marry
inner you know interracial marriage gay
marriage the right to vote like these
things are being pulled away and
eventually the people that were cheering
these [ __ ]
fascists on are gonna look around and
realize that now they're part of the
group that's been suppressed that's
being restricted yep
yep okay now let's just
check in with what um happened last week
in the republican party here we go guys
[Music]
god breaks bill gates
now that i've said that to satan and his
minions
[Laughter]
let us move
to the news conservatives are becoming
cool
oh they sure are rick we're gonna take
sex education out of the schools and put
it back in the homes where it belongs
the left control contact big media the
left controls higher education left
controls hollywood it controls big
corporations it controls big sports
twitter is nothing it's powerless
and how we really make it powerless is
we leave i want my twitter account back
a lot of americans have told me
the last couple years you can change
that we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel now some people
think this was a gap i think this is
just president trump josh hedging his
bets the former president's
obvious keen mental acuity they calling
me stupid that you voted for trump in
obviously 16 20.
would you vote for him again in 24 you
know i don't think he should be our
nominee rather than talking constantly
about the last i don't talk constantly
but you brought it up i didn't
you brought it up
excuse me you brought it up i didn't i
don't talk about it very much i don't
claim to be a journalist i claim to be a
talk show host right now we're going
outside this country to get things made
and they don't have the regulation but
we bring them back in this country where
we get all the regulation and getting
things made the sex trafficking cabal
they make billions of dollars off of
harvesting kids there you can see it uh
it's very very clear it doesn't move day
or night it's demonic it is a satanic
portal uh it is access to this earth uh
by those who are evil and only by
closing it we'll be we will be
successful in saving uh this nation
under god round of all the muslim
marxists who try to stage that coup but
general flynn made sure that wouldn't do
all the hollywood petty's the mainstream
media too
john it sucks to suck man
marjorie taylor green i mean talk about
someone who whines so much about getting
her account back and how she was oh my
voice was suppressed and they were
silencing my voice and my first
amendment right and then she's like
people shouldn't even be on twitter i
don't even want to be on twitter yeah i
know
yeah
what happened to uh truth uh what what
oh
what did trump talk about trump he
called no he yeah he called it uh tooth
central yeah
it sounds it sounds like a like a
discount dentist doesn't it right like i
would go there like maybe i track how my
teeth are doing you know i got a cavity
today oops you know you get a two dollar
root canal at two central right i mean
why not [ __ ] but
look at the craziness i mean you have
uh roger stone thinking that satan is
hovering over the white house i'm pretty
sure that was just a smudge on the lens
right he's like look at the light look
look it's it's photoshop it's photoshop
it's not that hard i mean you can like
put out a craigslist ahead and hire
people to
to photoshop anything you want never
gonna let you
go
how do you think
how do you think i got you as a guest i
know y'all craigslist i'm the craigslist
guest that's why i'm here
no you know the the best one of them i
get you guys cheap
i know what hey i was i'm free it's fine
right right right well i i have to pay
to come on this show some people surmise
that you could but listen the best the
best clip of all those that they had in
there is the alex jones one at the front
when you watch that clip it it is
[ __ ] crazy he's like yeah demonic the
bill gates we will send you to hell
and now
for the news
i was like man i need to do my cold open
like that like good god like that's
it's like like a gargly batman at the
beginning of the show yes and then he
shows you know
a winged satan and he's like and now on
to the show
and now to the news
it's like um
oh and then uh dr oz
we could stop being mushrooms
what
i don't like i mean does that mean that
they're all growing on [ __ ] like i i
don't
i have no idea i don't know
but he showed up he had trump had that
rally yesterday which by the way was a
complete mud fest i don't know if you
saw photos no it was rained on no one
was around the best one the best one
gave his
this lady they're interviewing this lady
and they're like well we came to drain
the swamp we didn't know we were going
to be in the swamp like
it's like honey don't hold the rally for
the last like five years was there
anybody there
well dr oz was there and he got booed
exactly
yeah they were booing him
like even when trump even when trump
talked about him they were booing him
and then trump talked about john the
owner of the company johnson and johnson
and the crowd is just like what the [ __ ]
why are you talking about this guy the
guy who owns johnson and johnson like
literally they they can't you know the
claim has always been that donald trump
reads a room really well and he he molds
to the crowd in the room that's all
[ __ ] [ __ ] he just he just tries
to sling stuff out there to see if it
works and then if it doesn't work he'll
change his tune that's why sometimes
when you're watching him speak he'll say
two different things right he'll say one
thing and then say the exact opposite
because the first time he put that ball
up on the t he whiffed it right lift it
and then he's like well maybe this crowd
likes the opposite so then he says the
opposite [ __ ] well that the date the day
before the last thing on the on the dr
oz thing is the day before
everyone was talking about how they were
going to boo dr oz when he got brought
out like everything they knew that he
was gonna knew it was gonna happen and
they still brought him out and they
booed and it was like
oh my god i don't know what to do about
this
and you know and then you have trump
saying
jd mandel and then like he totally
screws the guy's name up and then
then of course fox news i think he was
just trying to hedge his best oh no
no no he's a freaking [ __ ] yeah mr ace
the cognitive test over here right
didn't remember the guy's name he was
just like oh [ __ ] this guy i don't know
who he is i'm supposed to say some name
i'm gonna go off the teleprompter like
maybe you should stick to the
teleprompter my guy you know
he doesn't know how to read yeah that is
true yeah i mean he never wrote his book
right he had ghost writers
but he's a great businessman great great
great great job john did you know that
we had the actual jd mandel we
interviewed the actual jd mandel that
that trump mixed up it's over on our
youtube channel if if we can plug this
right here just go go just type in the
tony michaels podcast on youtube and
that jd mandel exclusive interview is no
one else has interviewed him no one else
has interviewed this guy you gotta go
everyone go watch that later on after
the show after the show just go search
turns out there was some drama between
jd vance and jd mandel is the whole
history they go into it
apparently he might have stole his
girlfriend or something i don't know at
a party you got to go you got to go
watch that so no no i know you know
how'd you end up getting him on
i don't know gave
you yeah yeah i i talk i knew i know
somebody who knows somebody who knows jd
that you know john we we like to poke
fun at these people we do parody and
satire every once in a while because
gabe gabe loves his wigs i don't know if
you've seen gabe's videos but he loves
his wigs and he has this uh this trump
hat that he always wears that always
appears to say something different than
um
than just a maga or make america great
again
but uh what's what the video what's the
video we're watching now what do we got
going oh here's his oh there you go
there's there's jd mandel's head yeah
this is the hat i'll wear this for the
rest of the show if you want to say
trump knows my name
that's the hat jd mandel wears giant
how'd you get the hat gabe did you steal
it from him uh it was part of the deal
oh i get you yeah to get him on the show
he you know i was like but is he goofing
about that because trump screwed up his
name
oh you got to go watch yeah you got to
go you'll understand you'll understand
after the show go watch the interview
you'll understand and then maybe maybe
next week you can play it for one of
your special guests and see if they'll
react to jd mandel
i'm talking about how jd vance may or
may not have boinked his girlfriend
mm-hmm well you know what i i do uh love
the lincoln project so i want to tell
you one more thing okay
selection is a simple choice last time
republicans were in power they helped
billionaires pay less taxes than you
this time it's even worse the republican
plan will raise taxes on over half the
country
democrats have a different plan raise
taxes on billionaires so you pay less
taxes a simple choice republicans you'll
pay more in taxes democrats billionaires
pay more
the lincoln project paid for and is
responsible for the content of this
advertising just i mean isn't that like
yeah rick's i just want to point out
rick scott's a piece of trash like
[ __ ] piece of trash the worst
the [ __ ] worst little tidbit here i
used to work with rick scott's daughter
back in san francisco and even she
didn't like rick scott
his daughter yeah his daughter she went
to school and got uh she was a major she
majored in sociology
which by the way at one point during his
speech
he [ __ ] ragged on people who go to
school for like the uh the arts and
sciences and and got and get sociology
majors and [ __ ] threw one at her
which is funny he basically just [ __ ]
all over her degree yeah but he came in
one day he and uh his wife came into the
office
and uh rick's got you you've seen him
yeah yeah i've met rick scott in person
he came to visit his daughter in the
office and she was like oh god you know
my dad's coming she's kind of like the
black sheep of the family there's his
whole backstory and drama is she really
the black sheep are they the
well i mean you know let's just say this
she had blonde she was uh she was like
the you know white girl blonde hair
thing at one point she dyed her hair red
and then her family made her dye her
hair back blonde and now when you see
how old is she when they made her oh i
don't know 30 something i don't know did
you shake his hand did you shake his
hand no no no no no
i wanted to know like how cold his hand
was oh you know like
like that's the type of vibe this guy
has they came into the office and me and
some other people were like oh [ __ ] this
noise and we just left and just went to
go work from a cafe but it was
it was crazy but yes i've worked with
her i've met the guy in real life and in
real life and also within his family and
on tv and his politics it's all [ __ ]
tragic but it's just what the thing that
i mean that is great about that ad
is that all these right-wing lunatics
all these trumpers that go to these
rallies
they don't know that the republicans are
screwing them in tactics oh yeah not at
all oh well yeah well yeah they have no
idea they have no that's what i mean i
mean and it's democrats that don't do
the proper messaging to let them know
and go do you realize we're trying to
tax the billionaires and not tax you as
much do you realize that they're trying
to
these people that's like the whole plan
that was proposed before which is like
if you make over four hundred thousand
dollars then you will be properly taxed
but if you're less than that then you
have nothing to worry about and then
they've got people worrying you know
regular average joe schmo is now
worrying that you know joe biden's gonna
come reaching his hands into your
pockets and taking your money right out
but that's not the case but republicans
are very good at the fear-mongering
right they're very good at the
bait-and-switch right they make it the
proposal but then they blame it on the
on the democrats and it's it's very much
that that's that is their mo and that's
what they do and so when it comes to
anything that would be of a social good
program for anyone in the country
republicans say and actually socialism
they're trying to they're taking stuff
away or or they're they're overreaching
overbearing government which is the
complete opposite of what's being done
and if you look at the growth rates of
jobs and the economy and just the
overall country when you compare
a republican administration to a
democrat
administration you see that it's a it's
a complete opposite where there's
negative growth and then there's
positive growth like it's it's
undeniably the truth but republicans are
very good at spinning it to say
democrats are socialists and marxists
and they're trying to they're trying to
take away your rights and they're trying
to reach in and take your money when
it's the complete opposite you know so
and as joe bell says for you gabe rick
scott looks like voldemort oh yes hands
down
there's a there's a photo if you if you
google rick scott laughing
online there's a photo of him where he's
got his mouth open and his teeth
and it looks [ __ ]
it's it's it it's the thing that is like
nightmare fuel
oh my god you know i i do have to say
because john you brought up democrats
messaging and liberals messaging you you
want a message they're trying to they're
these republicans in tennessee are
trying to marry teenage girls is that
who you want in charge of your taxes do
you want someone who's trying to marry
children in charge of your taxes in
charge of your gas prices do you want
that do you want those people in charge
of your economy you want them in charge
of your health care the people who are
trying to marry children in tennessee
are you kidding me
banning math in florida that's the
people you you want people who don't
know math because they're banning it
because math is crt you want them in
charge of gas prices in the economy
they're not even going to be able to
count here soon if they still can for
[ __ ] sake
i know right now here's your immigrant
myth is this the shot that you were
talking about gabe hold on
hey did you find it i think i might have
are you going to scare you're going to
terrify your [ __ ] audience here
is this yeah that's it that's the photo
and it's not edited it is the actual
photo of him laughing oh man [ __ ]
creepy yeah yes tonight all of your all
of the people watching this show will
get nightmares oh my god those [ __ ]
eyes man i forget his mouth i know
he looks like he's he is one
[ __ ] man
you want that guy in charge of your
taxes that's what you want in charge of
your taxes is that [ __ ] he's the
same he's the same [ __ ] that
shut down lines early in 2012 when
people are trying to vote in florida
because remember he was the governor of
florida during
obama's re-election
and drinking with florida what the
hell's wrong with florida
is what the [ __ ] there's nazi did you
see this there is nazis yeah protesting
at disney nazis actual [ __ ] nazis
not like not like oh they're you know
they're republicans and you know i'm not
being there they're holding nazi ss
flags
and they're the group they're the group
that's like oh no the difference is
they're outgrowing
you i think well no i didn't i retweet
it
oh yeah patriot takes put it out and i
retweeted it and i said i said something
like uh and people call me crazy when i
say rhonda santos is a nazi like you're
calling me crazy when i call ron
desantis a nazi here's his nazi clan up
there [ __ ] supporting to boycott
disney or whatever the hell they're
trying to do i mean this is the same
group that has a let's go biden banner
over us uh over a freeway and has a nazi
uh
yeah let's go brandon let's go let's go
brandon and then it's the same let's go
brandon exactly and they're like oh no
we're not nazis and it's like
too bad man you guys got [ __ ] going
all over the place with their [ __ ] ss
symbols and and swastikas you are the
nazis i'm sorry
well there's a lot of reasons to boycott
disney and none of them have to do with
the reasons that they're saying but
don't you find it hilarious john that
all these these self-proclaimed free
market capitalist republicans who love
oh they here's the picture yeah there's
there it is there yeah um with the ss
look over
and they're okay walking the streets
with that well i mean they hey i i am
okay with them being okay with showing
us who they are really yeah i like to
see their faces show me the face don't
be a snowflake don't be afraid
i want the country to see that these
[ __ ] people the people who are
telling you to boycott disney because
they're trying to make
goofy and mickey [ __ ] on air this
they're nazis they're actual [ __ ]
nazis
this is not hyperbole this is real they
are [ __ ] standing there with nazi
flags i'm not just making this [ __ ] up
when i say they're nazis because i call
them nazis all the time but you know
it happens no i know it is it is
it's so sick what's going on in this
country and i i can't
like the one good thing if if hanging
out at my pub
has any uh benefit because you know most
of them are right-wing
you know loons
but you go you go to the right-wing bar
willingly walk into a right-wing bar it
isn't a right-wing bar
okay
there are some people there
that are like hannity fans and tucker
carlson oh my god what are they seeing
those rubes but even those people are
going this abortion thing i think
they're going too far here this is going
to hurt the republican party damn right
it is like so even if they can notice
that that this is bad for them yeah
well why do you why do you think why do
you think the republicans freaked out
about this leak the reason why they
freaked out and they want everything to
be on the leak is because this decision
came almost two months early and it's
given it's given the the
the crowd as it were that's going to
vote against him an eight week six or
eight week head start on on on rallying
the troops to go vote against these
[ __ ] fascists and they're like holy
[ __ ] they got two months of a head start
here i mean that's what they're really
freaked out about is that they haven't
even picked out their candidates yet and
here we are we're like we don't give a
[ __ ] you got an r next to your name
you're a goddamn you're one of these
[ __ ] boycott disney let's go brandon
nazis right and we're done with you like
and even some of these republicans like
the people that you're talking to at the
bar john i would suspect that these
people are either going to not go vote
or they might just hold their nose and
vote against this stuff just to get just
to get their party away from these
[ __ ] extremists
that's what i hope happens i think you
know like you know that's why i
seriously think
like house box has been saying it for a
while that
you know don't be worried
we're gonna win seats in the midterms
he's been saying that well you should be
worried enough to
engage you don't want it you don't want
to yeah
you're going to take your foot off the
pedal here but right right right i
[ __ ] throw gasoline on that fire
right now that guy's like rarely wrong
but
i think now
with this
abortion thing
they are they are really shooting
themselves in the foot man well i mean
the majority of the country is a
supports it
and you're you know again you're you're
using the highest court in the land is
deciding what the minority of the
country wants
there's something wrong here and there's
something that needs to be looked at and
whoever whoever leaked it i don't give a
[ __ ] whoever leaked it but this should
be used on the left as a means of
pushing the na pushing the messaging
whether it's marrying little kids or
taking away your books or or being
afraid of math or whatever the [ __ ] it
is or taking away women's rights because
it's a slippery slope from there like
this is something that should be used as
as fuel as as energy you know and the
other thing is
that um
uh
now they don't have a wedge issue
anymore because if if it if it is
overturned
the republicans don't have that to get
these right-wing loons right support
them anymore
because that's what they use it for you
know right well i i think that there's a
viable argument there but i mean
don't don't doubt these fascists they're
going to go one step further you know
like i said earlier just because they
they think that you know just because
maybe you think all they want on this
wedge issue it doesn't mean they're
going to take it further and further and
further and further i mean they want to
criminalize um
they want to criminalize a woman getting
even considering getting a medical
procedure at this point i mean john
they're they're literally going to their
next target is going to be contraception
and they're going to go as far as to
probably ban condoms and i can't wait
for the day
that a bunch of these [ __ ] trumped up
fragile ass tucker carlson sean hannity
type white dudes out there turn around
and they're in one of these red states
and they go into a store and they're
like well this is the last batch of
condoms we got like what do you mean
like what were banning condoms like what
like why are we banning condoms like
well you elected these dumb [ __ ] to be
in charge so now condoms are [ __ ]
banned yeah like
again it's the same people that are
cheering them on right now are gonna
look around and be like oh [ __ ] like we
just [ __ ] ourselves hard you know
chris and it is no pun intended no pun
right yeah i know yeah no but it
honestly yeah oh sorry i'll leave no no
no thanks for two bucks you're saying
you know they're coming for our birth
control next
yeah easily because here's the thing
they're going to say they're going to
argue even though if they want to quote
the bible they can they can say that the
the first you know birth is when a child
takes its first breath right but they
don't want to use those things just like
earlier when we were talking about like
oh the passage of homosexuals like they
want to pick and choose they want a la
carte they want to do whatever they want
so that it fits their narrative and says
oh this is the word of god this is
exactly what it is right we're killing
babies but you look at contraception and
contraception is pre
uh pre pre uh like conceiving of a
conception of a baby right so they want
to use it as say like
what we want to do here is we want to
prevent
the possible death
of a fetus or of a child or whatever and
if we can remove it then it will never
be a problem and then we'll never have
these abortions we'll never have these
deaths or whatever so they're going to
ruin any any obstacle in in the possible
death
of this
this being right this little that calls
yeah exactly
more than a couple of
look look you can have as many places
you want you can pick and choose if you
want dessert for your meal or if you
want only like
carrots does jesus does jesus have the
the bible buffet does it have one of
those
the the the ice cream machines you know
i'm talking about it's got the whole
chocolate
yeah and then and then it's got the
[ __ ] sprinkle the sprinkles yeah it's
got a whole tray
with like the peanuts and [ __ ] but the
kids are always [ __ ] it up you know
they got the peanuts and the [ __ ] m
m's and the sprinkles
there's some of those [ __ ] are just
eating it straight out of my house you
know ridiculous man it's [ __ ] bible
buffet [ __ ] man that's ridiculous yeah i
just want to know if they have the
software machine that's awesome hey
listen i'm gonna uh
you know bring on my next guest so i
before i let you guys go yeah
i want you guys to say hi to my next
guest and then plug anything that you
want to plug this is yeah sure
you should have this guy on your show
he's the greatest this is the great greg
oliar greg this is we love we'd love to
have greg on yeah we'd love to have greg
on great i'm happy to come on guy you
guys are great anytime you know uh
greg we're on every single weekday live
two hours every single weekday monday
through friday we air from youtube
twitter and twitch and now we simulcast
to the minus touch facebook page um so
come come join us anytime you want just
just dm me or gabe and we'd be happy to
bring you on the show like i said we're
on every single day so yeah we'd love to
hear what you have today that's
ambitious you guys you know do it good
yeah i'm glad every every single day
live two hours we want to go to three i
mean maybe if we can get greg on every
now and then we could go to
we could go to three hours you know when
you just said we're every day two hours
i couldn't tell if you were like
touting the accomplishment or if you
were like every day
no no no no no no no no no no every day
it hasn't it hasn't lost its meaning it
really does mean everything it's
impressive it's it's really impressive
you know well i appreciate it appreciate
keep it up guys everyone go to youtube
uh the tony michaels podcast just search
us there you can find us there i
actually we got a video playing right
now the best of the week um and i think
right now uh the part that's playing is
the uh we interviewed jd mandel a great
he was hard to get let me remember jd
mandel the guy that the guy gabe's got
his hat on right now donald trump knows
my name um so jd mandel joined us so
everyone go after the show here after uh
john gets done with greg go check out
the tony michael's pod desk on youtube
and you can find us on all the
directories and you know hit like and
subscribe whatever the hell am i i'm
supposed to say you know that makes
sense smash that like button hit that
subscribe whatever the hell we're
supposed to yeah just pretend we say it
and then go deeper yeah yeah
all right
i love introducing all you know all of
us that think i like all together so we
can you know
you know have each other on each other's
shows so thanks tony and gabe yeah no
problem great just
dms don't be careful with gabe because
sometimes he sends kind of you know some
weird
he's sending me
i just i just send photos of republicans
but you can dm me whichever whichever
ones you want i'll see you on both
everyone okay great great great awesome
that's right we'll see you guys have a
good one have a good weekend
all right
the uh great uh uh tony michaels and
gabe sanchez and now a guest i haven't
had on in a while the great greg oliar
how are you buddy has it been so long
because i don't remember you having a
beard last time but now you it's like
you've been on a desert island for a
while
yes
yes when i grew up in greenbow
i have my girlfriend jenny
it looks good it's nice it's coming in
yeah yeah yeah uh well i'm gonna it it's
just out of laziness and because i
haven't bought a new razor lately and i
have to go to the drugstore and get them
get some raisins razors are expensive
you know they really are like i know
um greg i'm gonna do my sponsor and then
i'm gonna get into some stuff here with
you okay greg are you a betting man
i am now
well our partners at betonline.ag
continue to be the number one source for
all your betting needs and sports info
find all of the latest sports
developments including updated odds on
the playoffs fights and even next
season's futures and don't forget that
baseball is back and the start of the
major league baseball season is finally
here
although two raindown games the yankees
pissed me off but online.ag is your
continued source for all your sports
wagering needs including live betting
and your favorite vegas casino and poker
games it's super easy to get started so
head to the website today or use your
mobile device to join and use our promo
code clns50
that
clns50 to receive your 50 welcome bonus
on your first deposit bet online.ag
where the game starts
and now i can get rid of that and we can
get back to business here so greg
i haven't talked to you but
not much has happened since we've been
on yes but let's get to the
news of the day
the most disturbing news
that i have ever
i guess seen in my lifetime that they're
now gonna try and take the reproductive
rights out of women and you know what i
blame two people
donald trump and mitch mcconnell because
mitch was the one
who didn't let barack get garland
and then forced amy coney barrett on
this world on the supreme court so what
say you mr olia
well i mean i i don't think it's
possible to to you know overstate how
horrible this is um for a variety of
different reasons i mean it's just a
first of all you know where to begin
they all lied
the justices during their confirmation
hearings used words like starry decisis
i remember
cnn sort of making a big deal about
explaining what starry decisis meant and
what you know historical precedent was
and they all said they were going to
honor it and none of them did so they're
all liars and perjurers and if we had uh
you know any will at all we could remove
them from the court for that by trying
them for perjury we won't though because
that would be too that's too ruthless
and democrats don't play that way so we
should absolutely they should that's the
first thing um the second thing is you
know it's not law yet it's it's it's a
draft opinion
maybe something will change i doubt it
it seems like these are the votes
um you know alito has always been kind
of uh
scalia's little you know toady like the
little what's his name on the harry
potter the little you know dobby
whatever
that i don't know either the that that
his familiar you know like on that
vampire show where the there's the head
vampire and then the human that's coming
around and taking care of you yeah yeah
um that's who that's who elito is he's
just a
a milk toast loser who you know yeah he
just does whatever he's told and
you know the other piece of this is
these guys were installed on the court
by leonard leo
um who you know runs the federalist
society and um you know
the radical catholic opus dei affiliated
uh splinter group of catholicism that
all had its basis at the catholic
information center in dc
clarence thomas and uh scalia were you
know really active in that group this is
a group that does not like you know
women having any power at all this is a
group that doesn't like gay people at
all doesn't think they exist blah blah
blah just wants to take all the rights
away
and hurl us backward into
a time before the new deal that's what
these guys are all about
they are fascists by design opus dei is
itself came out of fascist spain it's a
fascist you know mentality and that's
the sort of thinking that's permeating
the court now i'm not saying they're
members of opus dei to be clear i'm
saying they're influenced by the
thinking of it and it's all the same
people it's leonard leo who is only like
i think 57 years old and from you know
he went to public high school in central
jersey he thinks he's like this cool guy
but he's not this is a guy who was such
a [ __ ] loser and had you know
some sort of mental imbalance decided to
spend his life
creating a system so that this sort of
thing could happen i mean you know
mental illness i think is the key but he
if you want something that badly and
you're willing to do anything to get it
to happen it can happen so these guys
are all affiliated with him leonard leo
put five justices on the supreme court
he put roberts on the supreme court he
put uh this alito jerk off on the
supreme court and then the the gorsuch
and um kavanaugh and amy cove at barrett
those are all leonard leo federalist
society picks they're all
not just catholics but radical catholics
there's no real word for what they are
but it's not um you know i was
raised catholic i'm a confirmed catholic
i don't go to church anymore but i did
get confirmed i went to catholic college
i know a lot of catholic people this is
not the catholicism that i was raised
yeah and that's what these guys are
they're basically you know they they
they want sharia law
but under the guise of christianity but
it's no different than that they're very
dangerous
so i don't think they're going to stop
they're also completely out of touch
with
you know the
where they are in society like i think
they've had these jobs in many cases
somebody like clarence thomas is so
unself-aware
um because he's been there for so long
and he just does whatever his wife tells
him to do clearly
so you know we have leonard leo who is
an unelected guy who likes to be behind
the curtain i had a thread about leonard
leo if anybody wants to go check out my
twitter page and look at it
it was from an article i wrote last
february about him and what he does and
what the goals are
and he's a dangerous guy people don't
know who he is people should know who he
is he should be famous if you want you
said mitch mcconnell absolutely trump
absolutely leonard leo is really the one
to blame and you can blame jenny thomas
too
how okay explain how does how does leo
get
like these i don't understand how he
gets them to be
donald trump's pick or what george bush
donald trump became the president
because basically the evangelicals and
the the the religious right and these
guys are not evangelicals they're
they're radical catholics but it's still
kind of the same subset
they need to have assurances from him
that they're going to get their judges
on the court trump promised that he
would do whatever he would put
anti-abortion
our anti-choice okay so he's in the
court
that's why the evangelicals like him you
know for no other reason than that it
really is that dumb and that simple and
trump really is that immoral that he
does it even though i i you know what's
the over under talk about bet online ag
can we have a line on over under for how
many abortions trump has uh had his you
know people involved with i don't know
um so leonard leo runs the federalist
society he runs the judicial crisis
network there's a whole bunch of of
organizations that are not for profits
they're 501c whatever the [ __ ] they're
dark money groups senator whitehouse is
constantly talking about him and the
groups and how they overlap and how they
sort of not not evade the law but evade
the spirit of the laws that prevent
groups like this from engaging in
political activity um but that's what he
does there's an uh there's a [ __ ] ton of
money invested in these groups there is
a lot of money invested in
getting kavanaugh almost like he's um
you know how the hollywood studios have
a campaign to get an actor to to get an
academy award it's the same idea you
know there's
many millions of dollars are spent
trying to get these people on the
supreme court to soften up to do the the
the pr
um remember there was that women for
kavanaugh bus or whatever this is all
stuff that comes out of this and again
it's dark money we because of roberts
and because of these judges that they
put there we don't know where the money
comes from the money could everybody
says it's the cokes it's the cokes
the koch brothers and the koch thing is
sort of it's shorthand for something
larger i think it might be these
right-wing groups i have no idea that
it's not foreign money and until i know
for sure until they open their books and
show me i'm going to assume that these
guys are taking foreign money we don't
know that they're not complete full on
[ __ ] well just like kavanaugh how did
his whole house get paid for well you
know we don't know it's probably his
father paid for it you know his father
had a 14 million dollar uh
worth of of golden parachute the year
before but the problem isn't that
somebody paid off kavanaugh's house and
it was probably his dad the problem is
we still don't know you know kavanaugh
perjured himself multiple times during
during his thing anybody that really
wanted that had the the um the will to
go after him could probably remove him
you know as you know we've done a lot of
reporting on kavanaugh we've done a lot
of digging on kavanaugh um who's not
changed his stripes i mean this is a guy
who still goes around and you know i
i've heard reports of him being you know
visibly tipsy in public and behaving
badly even though despite all that's
happened this is a guy that there are
nine supreme court justices you know
yeah and it these people five of them
are buffoons it's it's it's insane so
anyway long answer
no it's okay lulu girl thanks for the
five bucks i think other requirement is
anti-labor that's what mitch mcconnell
really loves about these judges
yeah but definitely true
yeah anti-yeah pro-corporation
pro-presidential power anti-women
anti-choice
anti-civil rights of any kind yep yup
they want to bring in um fascism and and
or you know that some sort of
oligarchical systems united states they
want the us
to be like hungary or to be like
ultimately to be like russia that's what
they want but greg why see this is the
thing i don't understand
when or
will when or
or will any of these
these right-wing followers
wake up and go oh my god
they're trying to you know
do this
these horrible things and take our
rights away why haven't they started to
wake up yet or is this
this the moment that they will they are
starting to wake up that's my question i
remember i read that book fast food
nation um you know back when it came out
which is about like the fast food
industry at mcdonald's and stuff like
that and i remember reading in that book
saying mcdonald's doesn't even try to
cater to people that are never going to
eat at mcdonald's like the real health
conscious they don't even bother they're
trying to get the people in the middle
to say oh well maybe i do want a big mac
right now or something but you know
they're and similarly there's a subset
of people that believe this [ __ ] you
know that absolutely believe it they
think that you know the bible says
something about gay people and you know
sodom and gomorrah and all this
horseshit fiction you know yeah it's
horseshit but it's also it's a story
it's a made-up story from a long time
ago that has zero basis in reality and
they think that you know that's it and
therefore gay people should be i don't
know stone to death because that's what
it says which it doesn't even say but
whatever um there are people that are
like that that are just nuts and we're
never going to get through to those
people i do think there are people that
are just apathetic i think most of the
electorate or the potential electorate
is just apathetic either they don't care
or they uh i don't think was that true i
think that was a joke that he lost his
briefing oh really uh that was the new
yorker guy um the the uh they're
apathetic and we have to get through to
these guys you know we have to get
through to
um the people that are apathetic that
have been sitting it out that's always
the case when when voter turnout is high
enough the democrats always win because
most of us are democrats that's just the
truth the republicans vote more because
they they know they have to and they
prioritize it we don't prioritize it
we're lazy about it our side and we have
to be not lazy and with all the the the
gerrymandering and all the other stuff
and the fact that the senate is rigged
anyway through the the sort of
anti-diluvian system to to it it favors
the former slave states which are now
the you know the mega states basically
the red states
by giving them disproportionate amount
of power so we have to have so many more
votes in so many more places just to
break even that it's not fair
so um you know it's really a problem and
i don't know it needs something needs to
be fixed in this country or the
democracy is over you know it's already
we really have only had democracy since
like the civil rights act in the in the
60s it's you know people have not been
able to vote for all that long everybody
and the republicans want to take that
away they want to you know br
peel it back so that you know women and
people of color don't vote that's what
all of their [ __ ] is about
and that is why i'm gonna play this for
you greg nicki freed had retweeted this
and i would love to
i would love for you to watch this have
you seen this
no
okay so this is a woman
i guess at
some kind of luncheon and she is
explaining about what just what you're
talking about so hold on
i just got to mute my mic
i'm going to be quick to say what i got
to say because i know she has to go and
whatever but what i wanted to say i am i
am a born and raised floridian
and ain't no demon
in hell is gonna run me away from this
state
i'm never i don't care what they do what
they say they get they police's force
and all that i am gonna vote
and i'm not afraid to go vote
the one thing i know i'ma do is go vote
cause you are not gonna take my voting
rights away from me
and what i wanted to say to you
i pray we are prayer warriors and
everything and we got your name in the
prayer bowl
because god knows all he know everything
and so that's like i tell people that's
what they want you to do they want you
to say oh i ain't gonna go to the poll
ain't gonna
i'm going there big and bold
my freedom we had people to die for our
rights
and god said we don't have to fear and i
don't fear so know
that we are praying for you thank you
thank you
thank you
and that says it all to me you know
that's what i think is happening and i
this is what i hope is happening greg
is that
you know all these people of color are
seeing their rights being taken away
from them
and that is only going to motivate them
that much more don't you think
i hope so i mean
she's right and you know god bless her i
mean i hope that that you know that that
the spirit of that is something that
people carry out because we need it
you know but remember the
it's so hard even if we vote it's so
hard because the laws are so [ __ ] up
like in florida did i can't remember if
they passed the thing you know like
people with criminal records can't vote
right
people in prison i believe personally
that everybody should vote no matter
what i don't care if you're in prison i
don't care if you're a citizen of this
country you should never lose your right
to vote ever for any reason um and
taking away those rights
then it makes it it makes it easy to
marginalize people because all you have
to do is arrest somebody for some
[ __ ] give them a criminal record and
then they can't vote ever again or for
some you know length of time there's
lots of ways that that they try to take
rights away they try to make it hard to
go to the polling stations on election
day they close places they make it so
you can't vote early the voter id laws
are designed because you know you have
to show your driver's license and that
on its face you say okay well that makes
sense you should prove who you are but
people don't not everybody has a
driver's license so it's the onus on
people to go have to pay the money and
do that to get a registered id just to
go vote at a precinct in a place where
they live and everybody knows them
right it's not so
um
that's what we need
we need uh we need to turn out in mass
numbers or we're done if we if we lose
the midterms i think we're [ __ ]
honestly uh i don't know what they're
going to have to do
garland isn't moving fast enough that
anything's going to happen after that
that gives me any sense of of of
hopefulness and that's it you know biden
maybe he wins maybe he doesn't he's he's
he's doing a great job in a lot of ways
and i like him but he's not young and
you know they can if they can rig the
system and by rig i don't mean break
into the voting machines i mean rig like
make it so that woman can't vote or
makes it harder for people like her to
vote
um you know so the system is they can
use these dirty tricks to try to uh
dissuade people from voting
i don't know you know i don't know it's
scary yeah
do you know do you know pam keith
yeah i mean i know her on twitter
yeah so i had iran and she was like
really angry with joe biden because she
thinks at this point
biden should
get rid of garland
he's you know he's taking way too long
and you know and appoint
an ag that'll actually get a special
prosecutor to start really doing the
work because garland is failing us
he sided with trump with the ejohn
eugene carroll case and he sided with
trump on something else
so so he like i forget i always forget
somebody in the chat will probably
remember but i just you know it drives
me crazy i mean garland to me
is a republican
i mean even if we take even if we take
it at his word okay and his he's got
plenty of defenders and he he clearly is
working on the january sixth thing it's
not like they're not doing work they are
arresting people they are doing the
classic moving system not the bigger
people not yet you know and that's how
these things work right so okay i can
look at it and i can see that there is
stuff happening i can see it but it's
been a year and a half since then and
all we've got is some dude with an
eyepatch who i did not know who he was
and if i don't know who he was nobody
knows who he is okay so that's nice and
all but the problem is
nobody's been indicted for anything else
and the longer that that goes on the
easier it is for trump and all of the
trump backers to say hey if we were
guilty of crimes we would have been
charged by now and
you know the other thing about garland
is that it's been it's been quiet
you know that yes he might be working
quietly he might i'm giving the benefit
of the doubt great i hope that he is
in the meantime
he's he's had very few public
appearances every time he has one i
applaud it but like there needs to be
more of this stuff like weekly at least
somebody him or somebody high up at doj
needs to come out and let us know what's
going on not the particulars of the case
where things are going to get blown away
just assure us in the way that cuomo did
during covid every day at 11 a.m cuomo
spoke he didn't say anything new
necessarily each day but it was
comforting to know that he was there and
it made us all feel like [ __ ] was
happening and that they were on it it's
about optics the job and i said this
before even before he was even nominated
that job is about optics more than
anything we're in an information war and
even if he succeeds in indicting these
people which maybe he will maybe he
won't i hope he does i don't know he's
failed the information part of it he's
it's just it's a catastrophe if we have
people on twitter constantly arguing
about whether or not merrick garland
should resign because he's not doing
anything that is a failure of
communication by the doj it just is
that's a great point greg and good as
gold says greg's guest on his last
podcast had a great point that garland's
lack of action is deteriorating our
enthusiasm and we are fading yeah that
was jennifer reitman of dave magazine
who by the way you should have on your
show john she's great yeah jennifer who
reitman at dame magazine d-a-m-e yeah
yeah
if you put me in touch with her oh and i
wanted to do you a favor are you still
having that chat problem with stream
yard
oh yeah last night it worked but is
there some button i have to hit you
didn't have to talk to you i just wanted
to show you on the right okay there's a
there's a blue button that says comments
right right yep then on the bottom
there's a private chat if i hit private
chat now
then all the chats go away yeah yeah but
like it's it's in the replay that the
come of the comments i can't see after
the fact oh oh okay so then that's not
stream yard that's youtube yeah
so now i have to look at because there
is a button i think i was hitting the
wrong button yeah yeah i'll i'll check
that out because because now that i know
because i couldn't check it for you
until i went live just to see if there's
anything
because it's never happened to me but
that's what it is it's got to be
that you
turn it off
on youtube after the show is over
somehow even though i didn't go to yeah
i don't know i don't know it worked last
night so that's good um speaking of last
year we do have we do have a show on on
friday nights now called the 5 8
lb and i would try to do it every friday
the live show so one of these weeks john
you'll come on yeah how's i'll be doing
is you know is everybody over the lev uh
uh the zev celebs stuff well i don't
know that that will be you know resolve
resolve but uh she's okay we're we're
good you know she's okay
she's persevering you know
when when someone that you formerly
trusted damages your reputation with you
know
like like that happened it's it's you
know it's hard it's difficult but yeah
and you know what and and
you know i really like zev i just like i
i don't know what got him to do
something
you know
you know like you know so nefarious so
i don't know it just it just
you know it like
you know i i i haven't had them on since
because i just feel wrong about it you
know because i love
stephanie and you know and
and uh you know alice and gill and you
know i i don't get i don't get where all
that you know
but he's standing by because i dm'd them
and said zebby what's going on he just
said
you know you know the proof's in the
pudding just watch the show you know i
stand by it
so i'm like all right you know i got to
make my own choices then you know
yeah not not much journalism happening
in that particular story i'll just leave
it at that i don't want to i don't want
to comment publicly but the no no no i i
don't wish them badly i just think it
was a poor choice i don't think it's
right really i don't think it's smart
for any of us
to attack
like because we're all on the same side
here yeah trying to educate and inform
those who
are may not be informed so i mean i
think we should all be sticking together
as opposed to
you know like
you know a bickering in between us you
know what i mean yeah no i agree i agree
and uh you know
that that's how i play it i don't try to
i don't attack anybody if i can help it
i don't go after people it's not my
style i don't i think i think when
people see it like people you know when
when there are fights on twitter i don't
people don't like it it freaks people
out it makes people feel uneasy and
afraid and um i'm very sensitive to that
so i try to avoid conflict whenever i
can in that in that sphere
unless somebody tweets something really
really stupid like some guy said to me
because i posted about donald trump has
lied over 30 000 times
how do you know he lied over oh from
some liberal newspaper so then i pull up
an article from the independent uk
which is a british paper
and i go oh okay this is the fact dude
you know because i cuz i gave him a
bunch of different place like washington
post new york times independent uk
because i just want to prove
even though i might not change him but
at least let him see the facts you know
what i mean
yeah they're not going to look at the
facts they're not they don't care about
facts
i know i know
it's it's it's it's a sad truth but it's
true i mean they're not you know they
have no interest in facts
yeah
greg i gotta ask you this one so
so the madison carthon sex tape
have you had a chance to look at it
i don't watch cop horn it's not what i
do
call
not it's not for me it's not it's not my
my um
you know i i have that tab blocked on
pornhub i guess i don't know can you do
that so you haven't even seen it no no
i'm not watching that all right well
it's not any like it's not like you know
there's anything to be seen except you
know him humping his male cousin's face
you know while making all these lunatic
sounds and the only thing i'll tell you
about it is
ju only thing i'm gonna point out here
is the hypocrisy here's a guy against
same-sex marriage you know against the
lgbtq plus community and there he is
with his male
cousin
having sexual our relations you know the
party of hypocrisy
just you know continues every single day
greg
um
yeah the the uh i i almost feel bad for
him at this point i mean he they're just
piling on i mean he's clearly
not well i guess and
i don't know why they turned on him
probably because of the
the orgy thing yeah i did you see that
because i did watch that i've said this
on other podcast
i apologize if i'm repeating myself but
he was very sincere on that podcast i
think he was actually telling the truth
where he you know he went to washington
thinking it was going to be
you know these sort of exemplars of
conservative values and then they just
wanted him to go to these sex parties
and he was like whoa okay and then the
same thing with you know the the the key
bump off the of of cocaine
and you know maybe they just turn on
them because they realize that he's not
uh
um
you know capable of keeping his mouth
shut you know like paul ryan said keep
it in the family stays in the family
it's just like a merit of bad behavior
that they that they have to abide by to
succeed in the party so i don't know
you know who's doing it i've heard tell
that it's actually a local thing that it
comes out of north carolina it isn't a
federal level thing
um
i assume this is going to torpedo his
career but who the hell knows
stranger things have happened and
honestly just sharing somebody's videos
like that is kind of it's just gross
it's not newsworthy
you know
well
the hypocrisy angle is but yes that's
the only thing that i'm i'm clinging to
i mean the creepiness is a whole nother
thing i mean it is his cousin
but uh
it's just a hypocrisy that's the real
issue
you know
which seems to be always uh prevalent in
the republican party yeah it's it's the
hypocrisy party for sure so yes and uh
sansa chemtrap thanks for the seven
bucks
and uh let me see
someone had a good point say to you oh
um
julie elise don't feel bad from greg he
spewed so much hate
i know i know but i'm
i am a sensitive human and when i see
people being abused like that it makes
me feel i i
just do feel sympathy for the person
because i'm not
you know
a psychopath i guess yeah and uh
you know that's just that's just how it
is you know you feel you we should feel
some amount of empathy and
i don't know with that too it's they're
the those people the the the republicans
in charge are just so awful and so
um
ruthless you know that they're
they're just killing their own here
it's it's just strange
just strange
you know it is and uh
d world thanks for the 450 haven't tuned
in for a while do the work great to see
you greg great to see you too
you know i
did you get a chance to watch uh uh
uh biden's speech at the white house
correspondents dinner i saw part of it i
didn't see the whole thing yeah i got to
tell you greg it's just like obama
i mean he crushed it you know i mean you
know great delivery
didn't stumble
like everyone's likes to say you know
it's he's got the mention no it's the
other guy it's the former guy that's got
the dementia joe biden you know but you
know what was great to me greg is that
there you had
a president because you had uh trevor
noah up there
throwing jokes at him
you know and everything else and joe
biden is taking it and he's laughing
and it's just so nice to see
someone that is not so fragile and
thin-skinned that'll actually show up
and let himself get roasted
without becoming a big whining baby
yeah
yeah
um
i think the fact that trump can't take a
joke despite dishing out so much
you know that really tells you i hate
that cliche it tells you all you need to
know but it really does tell you all you
need to know like all he does is insult
people and the minute somebody tries to
do it with him he just he can't handle
it you know when
when obama torched him at the at the
correspondence dinner that year
and they showed his face i mean that was
really something i mean he was hurt by
that he was hurt by it yeah and uh
you know
but but meanwhile he was a birther
yeah
well there's no you know again there's
no
he's not trump
i think trump is so frustrating in a lot
of ways because
those of us who have empathy and and
stuff like that and and are capable of
being shamed
don't understand how he can do what he
can do but he is doesn't have empathy
and is incapable of shame at least in
any way that's meaningful so
you know he's
he just doesn't care you know it's just
not gonna work and uh
you know we're in a world of [ __ ]
because of it
i know and that's what i tweeted out
today it's like you know the stenches of
trump is still here and it ain't going
to go away anytime soon as long as you
know amy coburn barrett and you know you
know and brett kavanaugh and
and uh gorsuch is there this is just
going to continue because they're going
to keep on passing these archaic
uh these archaic laws i mean and
and
god
greg 31 only 31 uh percent of americans
want to see
um
abortion banned
31 percent
69 percent of the american people which
means
a significant portion of the republican
party
is for
uh uh roe v wade and yet
the supreme court is now doing
or not acting on the will of the people
well yeah um
but it's deeper than that i mean
overturning roe v wade is going to
trigger the laws in the states where
they have that i forget what what the
term of art for it is
once roe v wade is if in fact it's
overturned laws will go into effect in i
think 20 states
mostly in the south and the middle of
the country that will criminalize
abortion so
right away
people are going to die i mean women are
going to die because of this and
whatever your legal reason is whatever
the rationale whatever these [ __ ]
tell themselves whatever sam alito
thinks his god thinks
it ain't right you can't have you can't
put people in danger i mean the primary
role of the government is to is to not
put people in danger is to provide for
the common defense and i don't
understand why
protecting the lives of pregnant women
uh
doesn't fall under that category they
prioritize the cluster of cells and even
that's [ __ ] i don't think it has
anything to do with i think that the
life begins at conception i think that's
that's just window dressing that they
use to to fire up the morons i think
that it's really about fascism it's
really about controlling women's bodies
that's always been what they want to do
um you know subjugating women is always
one of the first thing fascists do it's
women it's gays it will be trans people
now that there weren't that many trans
people back in the original fascist
times but that's what's going to happen
now
um
yeah so it's uh
you know
forget about the the who how many the
percentage yes it's a vast a wide
majority
probably the people that are in the
minority don't understand what it
actually means because anybody
i think anyone would say okay
your daughter has an ectopic pregnancy
if we don't give her this pill to to
terminate the pregnancy she's going to
die and there's no viable way for the
baby for the to survive anyway
anybody would say yeah give her the pill
you know that
gliaborg but that's and a lot of this
stuff that's what it is it's a these are
medical decisions they're medical
decisions designed to save lives and by
taking away the ability for doctors to
have the full uh arsenal of stuff and
and options is
savage it's barbaric that's what it is
it's medieval
greg have you seen this video i'm going
to play it for you because i think i i
think i know the one is this the cops
yeah but yeah it's good yeah this is
what you're talking about you know what
i
mean
listen everything's gonna be okay right
just let me do the talking okay
good evening ladies
license please
where you headed
oh we're just out for a drive
headed to the border
oh no no we were just going up to the uh
hey there
what's your name
grace
are you pregnant grace
step out of the vehicle she does not
have to yes she does
show me your hands on the wheels pretty
step out of the vehicle
just really chilling man i get chills
every time i watch that greg yeah
it's well done and you know you might
look at it and be like well it's not
going to be like that but how the [ __ ]
do we know you know that
i i had um
i did an interview from my podcast this
morning with brent tannehill who wrote a
book called american fascism which is
really good and um you know we we don't
know what what's going to happen here
the states if it goes to the states okay
let's say that the blue states are all
okay with abortion and the red states
all criminalize it what happens when
somebody from texas drives to california
to get an abortion you know
it it's the same thing that happened in
1855
when a a slave escaped from the south
and went to the north like you know are
we going to have fugitive pregnant
teenager laws now
um
we're we're really going back in time
with this stuff and i think that we have
to assume
that they're going to take rights away
and we have to act accordingly because
they will they're again these are all
fascists that's what they are they want
their strong man [ __ ] [ __ ] whether
it's trump or the idiot in florida or
the [ __ ] in texas or what whatever
one of these troika of stupidity
or you know
josh hawley fist bump josh hawley the
real real man josh hawley yeah because
when i think of you know traditional
masculinity the first image that comes
to my mind
um
yeah
it's not good so i think that yes that
that that that commercial that ad is
designed to kind of make you think but
we don't know that that can't happen you
know well it it sounds like it will greg
because if if
if roe v wade is overturned and abortion
is made illegal
what you know how are they going to
enforce it they're going to have to do
[ __ ] like that no
i mean then it comes into the idea of
enforcement like how will they enforce
it how much money how much money do they
really want to spend on enforcing it you
know if you're
i mean legit if you're a cop are you
really going to want to like start
arresting people for that because i
wouldn't if i was a cop like you know
police ethics in school yeah
in my experience i know look cops take a
bum rap and for good reason but i think
that most cops are actually
good uh at least i like to think that
and get into the job for you know a
reason where they want to protect people
maybe they have you know different
reasons but i think at least the the
sort of the gist is i want to be out
there doing good i want to be protecting
people
like arresting pregnant teenagers maybe
not
that you know
drug you know you want to get the dr the
drug dealers you know the the money
launderers the the people that are
killing people and that and raping
people yeah but
that that feels like something that the
police maybe don't want to do certainly
the federal government's not going to do
it it's going to be up to the state you
know the states maybe the federal
government needs to give a lot less
money to texas and states that do that
maybe that's the answer you want to do
this alabama great you're not getting a
[ __ ] dime of federal funding enjoy
you know and then they're going to spend
their money on that and not they're not
going to also all the babies being born
have to
you know there's going to be a surge in
unwanted babies the orphanages are going
to explode what's going to happen to
that who's going to pay for that this is
an economic catastrophe potentially
and you know maybe it'll be a thing
where they just don't enforce it
but you saw with it you know what amy
coney barrett wrote in that thing about
how
you know like now
people who don't have children could
adopt
you know these children i mean
this is lunacy
so they're trying to now
uh
you know uh what is it uh herd children
that's what you
[Music]
so so people could have
these kids i mean this is
the most ridiculous thing that i've ever
heard of they have to hurt the children
john who else is matt gates going to
date come on
becky carpenter 58 thanks for the 10
bucks that's very generous
jonah greg should the number of u.s
senators be changed to represent a more
equal representation of our country
yeah i think so it should but it's it's
almost impossible to do it i mean the
the way around it i think is you have to
let dc and puerto rico be states yes
tactically nina burley wrote about this
right after biden got uh
sworn in back in in early february she
wrote it in
in 2021
the first thing tactically we should
have done was made dc estate because
then we get two more senators and all
this mansion cinema [ __ ] would be
out the window like if they push that
kind of right out of the gate
maybe they'd be able to sneak it by
without them realizing it i don't know
maybe maybe it would be they would be
with mitch mcdick head there he would he
would he would put a freaking
they didn't try
no they didn't try puerto rico could be
a state they didn't try you know that
they didn't try enough stuff but yeah
right now there are two senators in
wyoming which has i think fewer than a
million people and there's two senators
in california which has what 60 million
people or something so it's it's
ridiculous it's designed to be
ridiculous it's designed to make it so
the slave states and the non-slave
states had the same amount of
representation in government maybe just
maybe we should look back and say hey
um you know anything that came out of
slavery like that that was designed to
make slavery endure we should get rid of
including and the electoral college
should be gotten rid of too
you know it's all right let me just ask
you this in my last question because i
know you you got to go and i got a good
like
i i got to go do my beer on the balcony
for all my patreon and youtube members
and uh it's going to be a fun one today
because we have a lot to talk about but
greg
now look i think joe biden's doing a
hell of a job considering what was given
to him absolutely but i will side with
pam keith on a few things and and that
is just what you were talking about
now biden must know
that we want dc and puerto rico
statehood right he must know that we
want the filibuster
abolished
he must know
that we want uh like like all of these
things
so
by questioning you is it
this he definitely knows it
so is he trying to
to wait to see if we win the midterms
and then unleash it or is he just saying
that it can't be passed and is
it's not even worth the effort what say
you
i think probably
at least certainly initially he made the
same mistake that obama made which is
thinking that the republicans were
actually going to try to compromise with
him
um they haven't done that since the 90s
it's a waste of time to even try so you
know [ __ ] him you know don't try don't
waste time and because he was in the
senate for so long and i think he knows
mitch mcconnell really well you know he
thought he could work with these guys
he couldn't you know he did get some
really important things passed i mean
let's give the guy credit and there's a
lot going on
so much damage to the country that trump
did plus the ukraine foreign policy
situation i know joe biden went from you
know on the foreign policy thing we we
had a situation where you know nato was
was fraying um america wasn't a leader
on the world stage
russia was ascendant in like three weeks
now that he fixed that basically you
know ukraine happened that's sort of
like a
almost like a black swan event kind of
thing
the ukraine war happens and we're able
to take that and biden's able to take
that and blink in and the rest of the of
the team kamala harris and you know use
that as the impetus to reunite nato and
make everybody stronger in the western
alliance which um you know people roll
their eyes out but the reason there's
been relative peace in europe and the
western world since 1945 is because of
[ __ ] nato so when we get rid of nato
then there's going to start being wars
in europe again i know there's one right
now but those are two that's if ukraine
was in nato that wouldn't be the case um
you know and also
uh we promised to protect ukraine in 94
when they gave up the nuclear weapons
russia promised not to invade ukraine
the united states promised to protect
ukraine in the event of russian invasion
and you know we are helping them but not
in the same way that we would be if it
was a nato state so nato is super
important but you know there's only so
many hours in the day and i don't know
that he looked at it tactically i don't
know that they looked at it like okay we
have to be killers here we got one shot
at this we need to do this thing and
really get it right i mean
you know the voting rights thing was
everything that was the most important
thing to pass
you know the the uh
the pandemic too he had to end the
pandemic and get all the vaccines out
which he did that's that was important
but the voting rights act that stuff
needed to pass and needs to pass without
that democracy is going to continue to
atrophy
until it's just a fascist oligarchical
system in this country that's what's
going to happen
all right greg listen it's been great
having you back wow
we have to end on a hopeful note
are the yankees still on the winning
streak or is that over no they lost one
on on on wednesday night and they
haven't played uh you know again since
so okay
uh greg i always love having you on
please um
plug anything that you want okay i've
got uh you know my sub stack which is
just greggoliar.substance
please check that out if you go
subscribe to the sub stack um that does
uh keep the lights on and keep me going
i have my podcast called prevail which
is out every friday and now i have the
show with lb on friday nights it's
called the five eight we have a youtube
page uh at the five eight you can find
it on the twitter feed my twitter handle
is right here on the screen at gregoliar
and uh that's what i've got to plug john
thanks for having me on it's always
great to see you greg it's always a
pleasure please come back i wonder later
i will i promise i promise all right
greg thank you
all right the great greg oldie are on
the show i want to thank my guests today
tony michaels and uh
and gabe sanchez and of course the great
greg olio i also want to thank my
sponsor bet online.ag
uh i want to thank my moderators nikki b
and benny loco and i also
uh would like to thank all of you who
super chatted and who are youtube and
patreon are our members because it
really does mean a lot to me
and i work hard um to try and book the
greatest guests i can i tried to have
lisa lampanelli on for this beer on the
balcony but she's gonna she's gonna lay
low
and for
a personal reason that i won't i don't
know if she would want me to mention but
she's gonna lay low right now
but i always look to get
great comics actors on the show
and uh so we will see i will uh i'm
working on some new ones but today it's
gonna be me and steve grill talking
about our trip to yankee stadium
and to his favorite pub after yankee
stadium i'm sure he'll have some some
good stories to tell about his
observations
on your favorite host
stuttering john so uh this beer in the
balcony is gonna be very fun as we lead
up to the kentucky derby so um
for all you patreon and youtube members
if you're not one become a patreon
member at patreon.comstutteringjohn
or just become a youtube member
and uh
this tuesday a new show
uh which will be uh
um just trust me i'm really looking
forward to this guest on tuesday i think
you all
gonna love her
all right
ladies and gentlemen i'll see you on the
on my beer on the balcony in about two
minutes the stuttering john saying get